the year is 1988 and in hargesa at the
time in northern somalia
mig-17 fighter jets streak across the
sky back and forth above the city
on the ground soldiers are going door to
door looting warehouses shops even
mosques where families have hidden their
valuables
they thought they'd be safe but the
president siad barei and his regime
forces
are bombarding their own people from the
air
it's supposed to be the final blow in a
military campaign to squash the growing
insurgent groups challenging his
presidency
but
instead it marks the beginning of a
bitter civil war that will ravage the
country for decades to come
officially it still hasn't ended
what happened that an entire city
renowned as a mother of somali artan
has been completely destroyed in 1988
that's dr jama musa jama director of the
red sea cultural foundation in hargesa
at the beginning of the violence a young
dr gemma left targesa where he's from to
study in mogadishu in the south of
somalia
back home his city is under a strict
curfew and taxis and cars had been
confiscated thousands of families are
finding ways to flee the city across the
border to refugee camps in ethiopia or
further away to europe and canada if
they have the money
but there's one group who haven't left
just yet
in the city's radio station headquarters
in northern hodagaysa
a small crew of employees regular folks
like producers technicians and news
readers are staying behind to try and
protect a slice of their city's culture
before they escape
they're pulling cassettes and
reel-to-reel recordings down from the
shelves and packing them into boxes in
all thousands of them
now some of those tapes will end up
being sent to neighboring djibouti and
ethiopia but the rest are being rushed
down into an underground room that won't
be uncovered for years to come
like something straight out of an
indiana jones movie
they're hoping these audio time capsules
will be enough to save something of the
culture they're leaving behind there was
someone who thought that this is
something so precious that we don't want
to lose it i can't take it because i am
becoming a refugee and escaping from the
war so they decay underground in the
same compound and they put everything
that they can get from the national
archive of
the team carry these boxes up and down
those steps into the underground room
until they can't fit anymore in
then they seal it up
and leave their offices for the last
time
some of them will never come back
[Music]
the bombing went on for over a year and
a half and when it stopped 50 000 people
had been killed by their own government
the national theater the restaurants the
mosques and the hotels the very
buildings that gave this city its
nickname the mother of somali arts were
destroyed
[Music]
but in that room those tapes a
one-of-a-kind record of the country's
golden age stayed buried hidden until
the war ended nobody would listen to
what was on them for decades not until
dr jama came home to a recovering
hargaisa and made it his mission to
bring them back to life
saleem russian walla and from ted this
is far flung
in each episode we visit a different
city to understand ideas that flow from
that place
today we're exploring what was in that
room and why
under bombardment
a handful of people decided to risk
their lives and bury a part of their
culture to make sure that it wasn't
forgotten
[Music]
here in the us and in a lot of countries
around the world
when we think of national history we
often think of books or museums
but with somali um history or culture
it's often you know shared through songs
and through poems and that's how it's uh
passed down that's salsa abdullahi our
co-producer for this episode
she's a producer at the podcast kerning
cultures
in fact the somali language as it's
written today using latin script
only became a written language in 1972
that makes it about six years older than
me
so naturally when the cassette tape came
around it quickly became this vital tool
for somalis to start recording their
rich history of poems and songs i have
to play some for you guys you have to
listen to some of them please that's
what we should do okay let's do that
okay so we'll start with kine garden
and
this version is the durgorban version
but this one's a really another one that
i remember from back in the day
[Music]
that is a wide variety of instruments
happening
[Music]
actually ended up being a surprise for
me because i thought that it was a love
song which it turns out it isn't
um which is funny because it is often
played in a lot of weddings
um and i've been hearing it since i was
growing up
so i reached out to a friend on whatsapp
so she could help me explain
what the song is and give you the
essence of what they're trying to say
you say to the girl like all the po the
fate fate has brought together but the
ball is now in your hole the lyrics
describe an argument between two lovers
it's hard to break down because they
actually are using some words as
metaphors so it's not literal
it starts out with him saying
fate has brought us together but now the
ball is in your court i did you wrong
and you now have the upper hand
but i still like you so let's make this
work she's she's remembering all the
[ __ ] he's done he's done he's doing all
the [ __ ] that she's done and she that
recounts in it but i feel like the girl
is proper savage
and then it's like basically i want your
friend to have a podcast i love
yeah propa savage is description of
what's happening there that was perfect
[Music]
so as you can hear this music is really
alive you can imagine seeing in a
seafront nightclub in downtown mogadishu
in the 1970s hearing this blasting over
the sound system as people fight for
space on a packed out dance floor
but the way this music came into
existence isn't as innocent or
straightforward as it might sound
it involves siat barre the president who
was behind the bombardment we mentioned
earlier
as unlikely as it sounds it was him who
kickstarted this musical renaissance in
the first place the end goal is to
pacify the people this is libon noah
he's the manager of durderband an iconic
somali band from the 1980s so it was
institutionalized and government driven
because of the propaganda and that kind
of stuff and because of the socialism
era
so all the bands were state-owned quick
clarification here not all the bands
were on the state's payroll there were a
small handful of private bans too
uh there was the weaponry who is the top
top of that pyramid and the rest of the
groups that uh for some of the military
will have their own ban so somali music
was at its peaks
and 19
late 1970s to the early 80s while body
was in power it was normal for
government institutions to have a band
they recruited the country's best
musicians and gave them all the
resources they needed to make great
music they were basically civil
employees with salaries from the
government and it was all part of a
socialist revival that started in the
1960s when bade first became president
how did siabare come to power
and
what was it like when he started what
did he say he was going to do
um
so the way siadberg came to power
is through a military coup
in 1969
and he had a lot of grandeur ideas so he
believed in the people
he believed in giving back to the people
but he was also a textbook narcissist
and a dictator
it's really wild that this person who
was going to end up being behind so much
destruction
started out his presidency by
cultivating so much creativity but it
was rooted in propaganda and it was
rooted in obviously
trying to
at the end of the day
self-serve but whatever the end goal by
the 1970s and 80s his plan was working
this is what barry banned one of the
most popular groups around at the time
they were the band of the national
theater
[Music]
it says called october water water
which basically means uh what's october
october is ours
um and it's literally
a national propaganda song that was
created to commemorate the month that
ziad bere uh took power it's still today
is mesmerizing some of the songs the
best songs somalis produce
are the propaganda songs and it's
interesting because as i'm researching
the song and i'm looking through um some
of the notes i actually
came across an interesting comment
on youtube where someone's like yeah i
recall listening to the song in my teens
and it reminds me of a good time but
also a time that's
associated with pain
which is a feeling dr jama has too when
he listens back to these old songs i
hate the words but the music written for
those words was so beautiful and so
moving and so so so so touching in terms
of quality of the music if you want
really
very hard to dismiss them you know
because the trumpet the music that the
genius of that inside music that you
listen carefully you can hear every
little thing
it was amazing time it's just uh those
notes i don't think that time will come
back ever
it was amazing
one thing that was really interesting
about listening to some of the songs
especially again the durdurband were
very experimental so you could hear you
know reggae you could hear calypso you
could hear synthesizers
you could hear
music from you know rock and roll you
could hear it all
but again done in a way that is very
uniquely somali
in our music they're a bit of indian
they speak of arabic they spirit of
italians below british spirit of
classical the spirit of opera it's it's
unique you know this is like that kind
of that's what produces and that's what
makes homani music unique
it wasn't just the musical style that
was going through a renaissance
something else you'll notice listening
to music from this time is that a lot of
the singers are women
[Music]
there was a time that the female singers
had to change their name and i'm talking
40s and 50s
that they use absolute anomalies instead
of their real name
but that completely changed in 20 years
where in 70s
the female voice it
song
was the most
normal but also most popular thing that
happened in the society
[Music]
somali culture is inherently islamic and
by default that means that women singing
were seen as haram
or frowned upon
and it was even considered to hear a
woman's voice it's hype
let alone hear her sing
this actually changed when ciabatta came
to power
he had socialist ideology that
saw women and men
as equals
and he actually created a woman's
liberation movement
i doubt that he saw himself as a
feminist this was something that
just helped advance his agenda in my
opinion
and one of the areas that greatly
benefited from this were the arts
and this is the 70s and 80s so one of
the main ways people would listen this
music cassette tapes
radio stations did broadcast music by
the most popular artist of the day but
there were virtually no private music
labels in their place hundreds of small
cassette shops around the horn of africa
would record the music from the radio
and sell it back to the public as
cassettes
they'd even do custom compilations on
requests kind of like spotify playlists
for the 70s and 80s so you would go this
studio and you say i need
a combination of three four
known singers
and they will collect for you and then
create the specific asset that you want
so that became a
kind of a popular market
and and it flows immediately after the
the golden age of somali music so in 80s
late 70s early 80s you would see in
every corner of the city people who are
opening this beautiful collection of you
know cassettes that you would go there
and select and they
they make a copy for them in general
there wasn't much of a concern for
copyright law partially because most
music was owned by the government under
this socialist regime
so you could look at it like a kind of
tape swap scene that the government had
no real reason to crack down on
people were
enjoying their culture and their music
and
so we were progressive at the time it
just unfortunately happened to us and
we fall from grace i should say
in the years after the bombardment of
our gaza the north of the country
claimed independence and took on the
name somaliland
but spiraling from all of the unrest the
country was torn apart by rival factions
and degenerated into a full-blown civil
war
during the worst of those years the
1990s making music took a back seat for
many of the musicians the golden age the
infrastructure was gone there was no
recording no performing no more you know
uh earning a living
or feeding your family
uh
i suppose
the bad spirit has taken over the
country you know just they become dark
meanwhile that room of cassette tapes
was just sitting there
waiting for someone to rediscover it
that's after the break
[Music]
[Music]
okay now we're back to dr jama who left
somalia during the civil war and became
a mathematician in italy
in 2008 he'd been living there for
almost three decades
but there is now a wave of somalis who
chose to return to hargesa to help the
city get back on its feet and he was one
of them
at first he was mostly interested in
books and he started har geso's first
international book fair in 2008
i love book fairs so i love that
he thought if i'm gonna bring my
country's culture back to life books are
one way to do it
but he quickly realized hey we're an
oral society i should be looking at
cassette tapes too because a lot of them
were left behind and forgotten at the
start of the civil war what happened the
consequence that everything has been
destroyed
everything including the archives
but as i said where were the archives
first of all this is small
music shops
and then you had the radio her geisha
nowhere else you had an archive of music
dr jama he also started asking people to
submit their own cassettes
many had been kept as kind of heirlooms
in family homes all these years
and he asked people to bring them in so
you could digitize them for his archive
and once you get known as the man who's
collecting tapes
word gets around people started
literally bringing in boxes full of
tapes more than he could handle and the
miracle happened
every single person who had some
cassettes in their house came to the
center and donated
now he's got an office full of cassettes
thousands of them well his office like
literally sits in the center of the
hergesa cultural center and right next
to his office is where the uh
archives are kept um and there's these
you know floor to to ceiling
cabinets and you can see rows and rows
and rows of tapes
and you can actually see little writing
on them like what the tape is about um
it's fascinating
and it literally at one point i it took
one end of the wall to the other
and they are not all music but there we
are also some other material inside
interesting material that you wouldn't
expect
for example this is one of the tapes in
his archive
a radio broadcast of an old somali poem
recorded on the cassette and it says
like tariq
and tariq means the history of baudery
and what it is is the story of elmi
bodari which is basically
um somali's romeo and juliet
about this
man who fell in love with this woman and
and they became star-crossed lovers so
is this particular story one of those
things that would have been passed down
orally
yeah absolutely um the the way that this
story specifically has been told it in
so many different ways it first started
off as poems which then turned into you
know a story that people would talk
about kind of like our own version of
romeo and juliet and then you know it
would then be told in the radio as a
full-on
play or story that you could hear
and i love that it was memorialized
and now in a tape that you could archive
or you could find in in dr jama's
archive he'd be sitting at his desk
cataloging music and every now and then
rather than instruments he'd hear an
audio diary almost like a cross between
a letter and a voicemail
like a voice note from the 1970s and 80s
they were recorded at a time when a lot
of people were leaving the country to go
abroad because the civil war or the war
with ethiopia before that so families
were spread out across the world
and the the the educated young educated
the person who is outside of the country
do the same instead of writing a letter
send this back
through these assets and surprisingly
you are cataloging music as it is and
boom you get this much discuss it is
which is a purely private
but you get something so
you know
powerful
because it reflects the society your
society how orality was so fundamental
because it's more powerful more touching
hearing voice of your mother while you
are outside of the country is much more
than getting a message and a letter from
it
so he started cataloging what he had in
a
giant excel spreadsheet
then digitizing just himself and a team
of volunteers
but they're only a small team and they
have thousands of cassettes to get
through and for example today we have
almost 14 000 cassettes collected here
and 6 000 only
it
and
had what's inside so properly catalogued
and digitized it so there's a lot still
a lot of work to do
and this is where we get back to that
moment that we started the story with
the radio station employees frantically
burying as many tapes as they could in
that underground room
those tapes stayed underground for three
years until 1991 when somaliland
declared independence and the radio
hargesa team unearthed them
but nobody had really been through
everything that was buried in 2009
during his tape drive dr jamma was
tipped off about these tapes that they
might be salvageable and could he take a
look
and what he found was that to his
surprise the tapes had survived they
were still playable that last ditch
effort it worked
and we all these men and women who did
that
and then some of them they didn't even
come back to her gates after the war
because of they pass it away but they
did something so
fundamental and precious and act of
heroes to
allow us that today we can have these
cassettes one of the thing reason that
it happened is because of this you know
the old things are always more strong
and and difficult to be destroyed so
so i think that the quality of the
material was also helpful in that way
these tapes have been through a lot
aside from that cinematic burial in the
underground room
there's just the passage of time
if you've ever had old cassette tapes
they get dusty and the tape can break or
they have that tangly thing where you
have to go back in and jam a pencil in
there and twist the tape back up shout
out to the 70s and 80s babies
basically
there wasn't any guarantee that there'd
be anything usable on them
if they waited too long those tapes were
gonna literally fall apart
that was an emergency which is a
physical material say this material will
expire so we need to do something urgent
remember how we said earlier that
somalia has an oral culture
oh this is exactly the kind of thing
we're talking about music poems family
histories not recorded anywhere else
passed down through these cassette tapes
so bringing those tapes back to life was
the obvious move for dr jama he felt it
was one way he could heal some of the
scars left by the civil war by sort of
forensically resurrecting somali culture
as an archive
but
after a war there are a lot of things to
repair and people were asking why is
this cassette archive so important when
the country still has so much work to do
to recover from the civil war but i felt
you know as a cultural center as an
institution if we don't do today
we will not have the lecture and some of
the first require you don't hear
anything honestly but it allowed us two
things
to let the world know
that we have such an important thing in
our hands
and most importantly more than let the
world know
let
ourselves know how important is what we
have in our hands
dr jama told us that for him it's about
a bigger mission to bring the somali
arts to as many people as possible i had
one mission and that mission has been
delivered
let the world know this beautiful thing
is there
and we need to do everything to let it
have back for the young generation of
people
a record label released an album of
music from the archive called sweet as
broken dates
and a couple of years ago it was
nominated for a grammy at the end of the
day that arc is crazy live bands to
studio recordings to radio to homemade
cassettes to being buried in an
underground room
all the way back out to one of the most
watched award shows on earth
it's uh
it put it back the somali music
in on the map of the of the world
for me was
again after so long time
you know
it's somali music
recorded in her gaze
in this dusty place of that we
love so much
is out there in the world and the
highest level of
of nominations for me that was the
important thing and now a new round of
work has started
and actually what's cool they literally
launched a website where you can access
these tapes
um and and eventually eventually you can
sign up to be a researcher and hear it
directly from
the red sea foundation and from the
haragesa cultural center
and that's to me is fascinating that you
can pick a poem or you can pick a play
or you can pick a song directly from the
reserve and from the archives
from a literal box in an underground
room to if all goes according to plan
being accessible to anyone
people risk their lives to make sure
these recordings lived on and now dr
jama is figuring out how to keep making
all of it meaningful today
he says he dreams of walking down the
street in her gaza and hearing that
archive music live on in simple ways
like playing out of speakers in corner
stores and barber shops
living in the world like it was intended
that's what i what i i would love to see
and this archive could be really helpful
in that way put back
in the normal life
where
somali music deserves to be
[Music]
[Music]
far flung is produced by jesse baker and
eric newsome of magnificent noise for
ted
this episode was created in
collaboration with the team over at
kerning cultures a podcast that tells
rich in-depth stories like this one
about the middle east and north africa
our producers for this episode are
abdellahi hiwate getana and alex attack
production support in hargesa by ismail
oba our production staff includes
sabrina farhy elise
sammy case and michelle quint with the
guidance of roxanne highlash and colin
helms special thanks to vic sahoni at
ostinato records for letting us use the
music from the sweetest broken dates
album
our fact checkers are nicole bodie and
paul durbin
ad stories are produced by transmitter
media this episode was mixed and sound
designed by kristen muller our executive
producer is eric newsom
i'm salim reshamwallah
[Music]
is
[Music]
me